we're used to seeing new content for
games like the elder scrolls and fall
out but now Bethesda Game Studios is
getting an expansion of its own a new
studio in Montreal Quebec has been
opened in order to quote expand
development capabilities in console pc
and mobile gaming the new studio
currently has a core team of over 40
developers managed by eastland Schultz
former senior vice president of
publishing at behavior interactive he
stated our collaboration with Bethesda
Game Studios has been an exhilarating
and memorable journey already we're
thrilled to be launching the studio in
Montreal and contributing our city's
great game making talent to the kind of
games that Bethesda Game Studios is
known for the most recent of those games
is of course fallout 4 which has already
shipped over 12 million copies the
post-apocalyptic RPG received a 9 out of
10 from GameSpot so we're certainly
excited to see more from Bethesda for
more on the studio's upcoming projects
keep it locked at gamespot.com I'm Tony
Wilson you can find me on twitter at
chain-gun Pope and I'll see you in the
Commonwealth